oh hé Mike quoi de neuf vraiment quel était
le dîner de fabrication européenne comme
ce matin chez les Chinois quatre ans du
jour au lendemain d'accord, nous dirons à Nick
de larguer la moitié de l'équipe sur la position Oh
attends attends reste là
où tu vas fumer ah tu devrais  je sais
fumer après 10h00 peut-être que c'est après
22h00
eh bien tu as dit pas d'ours noir au lit et
tu es au lit viens aux appels du bureau je
dois bien t'emmener c'est ton
choix c'est le mien
Oh sois ridicule viens payer je  tu veux dire
c'est ce que je fais dans la vie qu'est ce que tu
penses payer pour notre style de vie ce rock
sur ton doigt vraiment tu sais ce qui
reprend ton [ __ ] de rock je ne le veux pas
si c'est comme ça que ça va être Scott
allez ne fais pas  sois comme ça c'est notre lune de miel
Scott je m'ennuie je veux quelque chose dans ma
bouche ce ne sera pas toi ce
sera autre chose eh bien ne pars pas ouais je suis de
retour